GOOD MORNING OF. THE RULES
COMMITTEE MEETING FOR THURSDAY
MAY THIRTY FIRST IS HEREBY CALL
ORDER. PLEASE BE ADVISED ON
AUDIO GOOD RECORDING PLEASE
A MAP CENTER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM
THEIR CARILLO. CERVANTES
FRIEDMAN
GALLAGHER.
GRAYSON HERE MAYES HERE AS AREA.
SALAS ROSE. WALDRON.
WE HAVE A.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA IS OUR MOTION ON
THE CONSENT.
BROUGH MUCH SOUTH SECOND BY
MISTER MAYES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
BAD SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CALLING AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE
CARILLO. CARILLO AYE CERVANTES
FRIEDMAN. GALLAGHER GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MAYES AYE MAYES AYE
NAZARIAN SALAS. SALAS AYE
BUSH HAS PASSED AND THIS RULES